defunding the police defunding the
police has to happen turn into your
badge gadget ron desantis decided to
fund the police some wanted to fund the
police we're funding the police and then
some but it's not just that on the
border crisis a group of migrants grows
by the hour abolish ice we need to
probably think about starting from
scratch we believe that securing the
southern border is important for our
country he's not going to support the
border being secured you know we'll
provide buses and provide them we i will
send them to delaware send them to
biden's house i'm not kidding hello mr
the price of gas is bananas gas prices
have hit a new record high in america
and expected to keep rising i'm sick of
this stuff i'm tired of this grandpa
that's too damn mad you may remember
kovid do you guys remember covid we are
looking at a winner of severe illness
and death where was that the medical
science didn't change the political
science change we need to clone desantis